so you got 10 grand sitting in your bank
account oh you fancy huh
but what's your next move let's talk
money all we talk is money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
with 10 g's you're sitting on a nice
little cushion you're comfy you're not
stressing over a parking ticket
oh the guac is extra that's cute give it
to me and statistically
you're already doing better than most
americans but don't get too cocky your
next steps are critical
if you want to make the most out of that
10k there's a process you should follow
you can go in three major directions and
i recommend it in this order
cover high interest debt stack cash and
get
invested go from red to yellow to green
it's like abc if you go from a to c
you're gonna fail out of kindergarten
the order is important and this is why
let's say you cover all your high
interest debt and you skip saving go
straight to investing
like everyone wants to do you're taking
on unnecessary risk
that's long-term money that is going to
be tied up in an ira
robin hood or coinbase account and if
you have any sort of emergency
well you're you skip saving and
now something came up and you have to
dip into your investments
before you should you'll find yourself
pulling money out of long-term
investments to cover short-term expenses
which defeats the purpose of buy and
hold
skipping saving and going straight to
investing is like buying a 45 000
car when you have 50k in the bank just
because you can afford it
doesn't mean you can afford it so a
major key when it comes to doing right
by that 10k
is trusting the process crawl before you
walk
walk before you run and run before you
enter the investing marathon
first up is covering debt debt is the
worst four-letter word known to man
it's worse than
debt is your worst enemy and the higher
the interest rate the worse the
enemy accumulating debt is losing the
interest rate game
and this is not a game you want to be
losing debt is only fun for the ones
that are getting paid
so unless your name is freaking sally
may freddie mac or chase
your name is iou you know how they say
that even bad pizza is good pizza
well that is the opposite even good debt
is bad debt but there's levels of bad
the higher the interest rate the faster
you need to get that out of your
life
so make a long-term plan for the student
loans and the mortgage
while make some moves asap on the credit
cards
personal loans and cash advances having
that debt
is as good for your net worth as
shredding money plus emotionally not
owing anyone feels great
it's like doing all your homework so you
can go do what you actually want to do
next up is saving saving accounts are
paying nothing
but who cares that's not what your
concern is in this category
saving is not about rate of return it's
all about safety
and liquidity stack that cash for the
short term
this is bills food bills medium term
this is saving up for something you
really want
in the next one to two years this could
be a vacation or a down payment on a car
or a home but long-term saving doesn't
really make sense
it's like using a piggy bank to save up
to buy a building
it's very hard to save your way to
becoming a millionaire at some point
you're going to want to have to take on
more risk and invest
but the beauty of savings that if you do
it right investing will be less
stressful which brings us to investing
investing brings compound interest into
the picture compound interest is the
hype man of the money game
that's your homie that's your amigo
that's your compadre
investing puts interest on your side
when you invest
interest goes from costing you money to
making you money
einstein said compound interest is the
eighth wonder of the world
he who understands it earns it he who
doesn't
pays it and the place to go for
compounding is the stock market which is
america's greatest wealth creating money
making machine
cha-ching with historical returns of
eight to ten percent a year depending on
inflation
the problem is 80 of americans have debt
and only 55 percent of americans are
invested in the stock market
my two cents trust the process
cover debt save up invest don't skip
steps
if you have 10k you need to cover some
high interest debt do it because then
you can get started
saving if you have no debt but you're
not at 10k anymore
stack that cash before you start
investing and if you're at 10k
after covering all your high interest
debt you have
options find the investing lane that
fits your personality
it's all about risk tolerance the older
you are the less risk you should take
which is more bonds and stocks and
holding commodities like gold and silver
and the younger you are the more risk
you can take invest in more equities and
go long on crypto
so just understand it's risk and reward
and remember
the best investment you can make is in
yourself you'll never regret
investing in books and courses to get
you smarter equipment to make you more
efficient
or putting time into watching videos
like this to elevate your mindset
and if you're still not sure about what
to do with 10k
save that money
thanks for watching this video on what
to do with 10k if you have not seen my
video
on why it all starts with 10k check that
out right here
and as always save that money all we
talk is money